so I'd like to tick through a few
features Eric let's start with display
because the displays here are very
different sure so pebble features an
ePaper display that means that the
display is always on just like a normal
watch when you're you know running
around when you're outside you're going
for a run instead of having to flick
your wrist or touch a button to see what
time it is you can just glance down and
see exactly what time it is and here on
the Apple watch you can see it looks a
lot more like my phone it's a
traditional LED display what about
battery because you yours can actually
last a bit longer on a charge we thought
longer we focused on making what we
think is an awesome watch as well as an
awesome SmartWatch it lasts for up to
seven days on a single charge so you
don't have to charge it every single
night um what about wait that one is a
lot lighter yes which then we made sure
that pebble would curve to meet the
ergonomics of your wrist it's also much
lighter so when you're going for a run
you don't feel it like bouncing too much
on your wrist and what about apps we've
worked really hard on that over the last
couple years we've sold over a million
pebbles it's pretty big for a small
company of just 150 people down in Palo
Alto but it's been also an adventure to
see who would start building apps on top
of pebble we have over 27,000 developers
who are currently writing apps for apps
and watch faces for pebble now it's
interesting you know I remember talking
to you and trying out the very first
pebble watch how did you make some of
these decisions so that are so different
from the way Apple and Johnny I've have
designed their watch I think we designed
it with the community in mind we started
this three years ago when we launched
the first pebble on Kickstarter since
then the community's grown is what do
you mean by community though I mean
saying you're getting feedback from p
exactly i mean we we've started this we
were just three people in a garage down
in down in mountain town in palo alto
when we launched on kickstarter tens of
thousands of people got interested in
what we were making they've given us
feedback on Twitter on Facebook through
our forums and we've built a product
that I think reflects the million now
plus people who are using the product
they wanted something that was
lightweight inexpensive waterproof long
battery life with a great screen and we
worked really hard to meet that how many
have you sold so far we sold over 95,000
pebble time
just a month